Moi, la danse, ça a toujours été
un moyen pour moi de m’exprimer
différemment que par la parole.
Sarah pour moi, c’est une des
meilleures B-Girls en France.
Elle a vraiment un style explosif,
féminin et charismatique.
Quand elle veut quelque chose,
elle se bat pour l’avoir.
La danse, elle a carrément changé ma vie !
Hello, c'est Sarah Bee,
danseuse professionnelle,
spécialisée dans le breaking.
De ma ville d’origine à Mumbai,
je vous embarque avec moi
dans mon quotidien, ma vie de B-Girl.
Donc, follow me…
Aujourd’hui, c’est le premier jour de compétition du
on est à Mumbai.
On est là, sur le toit de l’hôtel, pour
faire un shooting avec la team Red Bull.
Let’s go !
Le premier cercle,
vous vous mettez comme ça,
le deuxième, vous restez debout.
Ok ? Donc on fait deux arcs de cercle.
Ok, on recule un peu le flash.
Ok, un, deux...
Les battles, c’est mon moteur de base.
J’ai baigné dans ça depuis que j’ai 11 ans.
Je pense que pour les danseurs underground,
ceux qui, vraiment, ont commencé dans la rue,
c’est important et je pense
qu’on a tous commencé par des battles.
C’est devenu très commercial
et les gens apprennent à danser
dans des cours de danse où c’est plus
de la consommation qu’autre chose,
là, c’est différent mais après,
chacun vit à sa façon la danse.
La danse hip-hop, il y a une histoire,
c’est vraiment une culture
qui est vraiment belle
et je pense que c’est important de savoir d’où
ça vient et de savoir qui était là avant nous.
C’est un état d’esprit, c’est pas juste :
"Je viens, je danse, je fais
mon petit hip-hop de la semaine."
Il y a des battles, ça te fait kiffer de ouf,
comme t’as des battles, c’est nul,
parce que t’es là...
T’as des gens, ils vivent pas le moment,
ils sont là, ils récitent des passages.
Surtout aujourd’hui,
il y a beaucoup d’enjeux,
il y a des compétitions
où il y a 20 000 dollars à gagner.
Donc du coup, les gens, ils sont là, ils vont
à l’entraînement, ils sont aigris, ils sont vénères,
ils se disent : "Ouais, je vais tous les niquer."
Ouais, bon ok. Mec, assieds-toi,
tranquille, respire un coup, kiffe.
L’important pour moi,
c’est pas de gagner ou quoi,
c’est d’avoir son moment où toi, t’es content
d’avoir été au max de ta performance,
t’es fier de toi, t’as kiffé le moment.
Et puis ouais... Brille !
C’est ton moment-là, donc brille !
Tu peux perdre, mais tu peux être celui
qu’on va retenir pendant 10 ans.
Sarah pour moi, elle est généreuse,
énergique et captivante.
Quand elle a commencé,
il n’y avait pas énormément de B-Girls,
enfin moins qu’aujourd’hui en tout cas.
Et elle a forcément marqué l’histoire,
elle a gagné des battles assez tôt.
En tant que danseuse, déjà femme,
dans un milieu masculin qu’est le break,
elle a réussi à faire sa place.
Le blaze, il se fait avec les années,
il se fait avec les performances
et elle a prouvé plus d’une fois,
en France et à l’international,
qu’elle avait le bagage pour remporter des titres
ou faire, ne serait-ce que des belles prestations.
Quand elle va danser, je pense que
n’importe qui dans le public va ressentir.
C’est une des rares B-Grils, en tout cas pour moi,
qui me fait ressentir la musique
parce qu’elle vit vraiment ce qu’elle fait.
Elle est vraie, elle est sincère dans sa danse.
Elle est pétillante, elle a une énergie folle.
Elle est comme ça dans la vie.
Aujourd’hui, je parcoure le monde entier
à travers ma passion, la danse hip-hop.
Je travaille en compagnie. Je participe
à des battles, des compétitions.
Et est-ce que vous voulez voir
où tout a commencé ?
Et bah allez, je vous emmène avec moi !
Welcome to Chenôve city !
Donc ici c’était mon squat à l’époque,
quand j’avais 11 ans.
Manuela, ma partenaire,
qui est ma partenaire aujourd’hui,
m’a proposé de venir à l’entraînement avec elle.
Donc c‘est comme ça que j’ai commencé
mes entraînements de danse
et la première fois où j’ai vraiment essayé
mes premiers pas de danse hip-hop.
Donc voilà. C'était ici,
au niveau de cette barrière.
J'étais là !
Le premier pas que j’ai appris, c’est un freeze.
Donc c’est une pose "gelée" sur les mains.
Et du coup la position, c’est ça !
Moi, mes parents sont originaires d’Algérie.
Il sont arrivés en France pour avoir
une meilleure situation, on va dire,
au niveau du travail et plus d’opportunités.
Donc du coup, moi je suis née ici
mais mes parents sont nés en Algérie.
Quand j’étais jeune,
j’avais cette difficulté à m’exprimer,
je parlais pas beaucoup, de moi,
de ce que je pouvais ressentir.
Et du coup, la danse, ça me permettait
d’extérioriser tout ça en fait,
toutes les mauvaises énergies comme
les énergies positives aussi, la joie, tout ça...
c’était vraiment pour moi une échappatoire
et aussi un moment où je me retrouvais avec mes amis,
j’échangeais avec eux et je m’amusais.
Personne n’avait l’intention
d’être quelqu’un dans ce milieu-là.
C’était plus : "On est là, viens, on kiffe,
on danse, c’est notre moment."
Ma famille, ça n’a pas été facile dans mes débuts
de leur expliquer que
c’est ce que j’avais envie de faire
parce que pour eux,
la danse, c’est pas un métier.
Mon père ne sait pas du tout ce que je fais,
n’a jamais vu quoi que ce soit de ce que je fais.
Au début, c’était pas facile, je me suis battue,
j’ai dû leur montrer que je peux en vivre
et que ça va au-delà
d’une passion ou d’un sport,
c’est carrément une façon de vivre en fait.
Et pour moi, leur soutien,
c’est de m’avoir laissé faire en fait.
Si mes parents, un jour,
décident de venir me voir en représentation
ou même en compétition,
je serais trop contente,
je pense que je serais émue.
Je pourrais même verser la petite larmichette !
Nous allons aujourd’hui participer
à la première étape du battle.
Donc un battle, c’est la confrontation
de deux danseurs.
Donc on est en one/one, compétition solo.
Ça consiste à danser en opposé
et on doit faire un question-réponse.
Donc le premier qui commence,
le deuxième répond... Bam, bam, bam…
Les musiques, on les connaît pas.
Enfin, on les connaît parce que c’est du break beat
ou c'est des musiques hip-hop
donc on a l’habitude d’entendre.
Mais c’est freestyle,
c’est le DJ qui mixe
et c’est son taf de nous ambiancer.
Nous, on doit s’adapter à tout en fait,
à un sol sur lequel on n’a pas l’habitude de danser,
à une musique, on ne sait pas...
Enfin voilà, ça va être la surprise !
Chacun le fait à sa façon,
il y en a qui sont plutôt freestyle,
il y en a qui préparent vraiment tout de A à Z,
jusqu’aux "top rock" et jusqu’aux "freeze".
Bon, c’est bien beau de venir à la Red Bull mais bon,
il faut quand même se préparer un minimum.
Venir freestyle, c’est un risque
et je ne prends pas le risque.
Donc, j’ai vraiment travaillé des codes.
Je n’ai fait que répéter, répéter, répéter, répéter...
Et après, t’improvises sur la musique,
t’essaies de les amener différemment à chaque fois,
t’essaies vraiment de le danser différemment
parce que la musique te dit des choses
donc il faut que tu le vives différemment.
Cette compétition, je le prends pas comme genre :
"Wouah, faut que je défonce tout le monde."
Non, j’ai envie de montrer qui je suis et
j’ai la chance d’avoir mon propre style et ma patte.
Et du coup, à partir du moment où tu danses
comme personne, t’as rien à perdre, en fait.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?!
Nous avons 16 B-Girls
qui représentent leur pays,
leur crew, leur style et leur personnalité.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?!
Yeaaaaaaaaah !
Ressentez leurs vibes !
B-Girl Mimz, pour le Japon.
C’est parti, Sarah Bee.
Surprise !
Elle a sa vibe aussi !
"Tiger style",
ça peut être dangereux !
Bang bang !
C’est parti Sarah !
Qu'est-ce que
tu nous réserves ?!
Explosif !
Ohhh merde !!!
Ce battle vous a plu ?!
Ok, voyons qui va gagner.
Les juges, trois, deux, un...
Le mood dans lequel je suis après
avoir perdu la compétition au premier tour...
Je suis très déçue de moi-même en fait,
j’ai travaillé pendant des mois...
Et tout part comme ça !
Après, ça fait partie du jeu.
J’accepte la décision du jury.
Perdre n’est pas forcément une mauvaise chose.
Déjà, des fois, c’est pas ton heure
pour briller tout simplement,
donc calme toi, mets-toi sur le téco.
Il faut pas oublier que c’est de la danse.
On ne dansera pas toute notre life,
faut dire ce qui est.
Notre corps, il va pas nous permettre
de tourner sur la tête toute notre vie.
Oublie pas qu’avant tout, c’est un art en fait
et qu’on doit respecter cet art, kiffer,
prendre le temps d’échanger avec les gens, bam, bam...
Et quand c’est le moment de la compétition,
il n’y a pas de problème, vas-y à donf
mais oublie pas de prendre du plaisir, de kiffer.
Quand j’ai commencé la danse, j’étais une petite fille
de quartier qui traînait plus qu’autre chose,
qui avait pas spécialement d’ambition dans la vie.
Et la danse m’a permis de vraiment
me diriger dans le droit chemin, tout simplement.
J’ai été carrément une meilleure personne
dès mes premiers pas de danse en fait.